i watch this movie disconnect if you can
pull it up let's just start with this so
disconnect there's a story
uh with the actor what's his name
jason bateman okay so he's a great actor
phenomenal job but this story is a story
of a father
uh uh who is working doing what he's
doing his son
in a class look at box office look at
box office 1.5 think about it and i'm
telling you every parent must watch this
movie right
so
you know this father's got this kid he's
got a daughter and a son the son falls
in love with a kid in school girl in
school
and he tells another guy he finds out
but the guy tells the bully of the
school the bully of the school creates a
face a fake facebook profile with the
girl that he likes his picture on there
befriends all the people in school
thinking that he is the girl then she
reaches out to him and meaning he acting
as if it's her reaches out to him
saying hey thank you for your help with
some message like that on facebook so i
didn't even know you paid attention to
me so of course i pay attention to you
and then he starts flirting with him
thinking it's her
eventually the bully says i'll show you
mine if you show me yours okay
so
he's like really yes
so the bully sends a picture of some
girls you know naked and it's just the
bottom nothing more right
and the guy's like oh my god says then
he sends his picture
but he wants the the the bully wants him
to send a picture with his face in it so
he does
they take that picture the next day the
kid who goes to school everybody's
looking at this kid laughing at him
right he's like why is everybody
laughing and everybody starts showing a
picture listen
you send this message and the bully
outs and you know exposes them right so
this kid is devastated
doesn't know what to do he's 12 years
old doesn't know how to handle this goes
home turns on heavy metal music they're
wondering why he's doing that he's
hanging himself
in his room sister walks and holds him
before he kills himself father comes and
says what the hell is going on he says
finally they find that the situation
that goes to the other dads and then
anyways this story right here it's based
on a true story by the way it's based on
a tr and it's happening and there's
multiple there are multiple versions of
this i'll tell you what i've done this
on my youtube channel have a seat with
chris hanson in a case where a young man
same thing happened to him
and the mom went to
and not only was this an embarrassment
at school
it got into
different sites that it was being traded
for child porn
it went on twitter and was being
disseminated on twitter they went to
twitter and said take this down
twitter didn't act pretty well for for
months and months and months and months
and it's the subject of a civil lawsuit
claiming that twitter was complicit in
the distribution of child pornography
this is real life stuff this happens you
look at the case down in
in naples
not far from here
a girl was a very popular tick tocker
started during the pandemic 13 14 15
a guy becomes obsessed shows up at the
door with a shotgun blows open the door
the father is a retired lieutenant from
jersey city pd fortunately had a pistol
shoots him dead
stand your ground case we didn't find
out until
just a month or so ago that this was all
involved in a twitter type thing and it
turns out the guy who was shot dead the
stalker had been in contact with other
kids at her school to get information
about her see this is stories like this
that i mean it's it's you i mean look
it's all great to be on social media you
know it's a part of the fabric of our
society of our lives and kids should be
able to go out and create
accounts and be able to express
themselves it's all good but it's got to
be monitored and the thing that drives
me crazy guys
is you see these parents who are
exploiting their children not in this
case i'm not arguing that in the case of
naples but in other cases and i've done
stories on this where parents are
pimping out their kids in these quote
unquote family
channels
and and youtube sometimes doesn't crack
down on this stuff
so they'll
limit monetization on a on a show that i
do exposing this stuff
but the young girl who's being exploited
that show is fine they monetize the the
heck out of it it's it's insane so what
what do you do you're a parent you're
listening to this okay we've heard many
different things what are the guidelines
because there's a difference between
being too intrusive it's like dad leave
me alone mom leave me alone you know let
me have my own life versus absolutely
you know you know these guys are out
there you know they're not able to well
you have to look
when we talk about the drug problem
there's demand reduction we treat it as
an illness sometimes as opposed to a
crime there's no demand reduction
effectively for predators so your best
defense is education and the discussion
you have with your children at home
there's one discussion when they first
get online and have a phone
there are adults out there who want to
trick you kids don't like to be tricked
and as they get older and as you allow
them access to different areas of the
internet you have to up that
conversation
and be very straight up with them and
say look you don't want to hear this
from me
but
i do this for a living i talk to people
who live in this world and and it's
dangerous if you don't apply these rules
they used to say to us when we were
growing up don't talk to strangers good
advice then good advice today but the
problem is the stranger on wednesday is
so adept at grooming your child right
that he's not a stranger on saturday
and i read these transcripts when i go
back and do the podcast predators i've
caught i go back in the cases that we've
already done and i immerse myself in the
transcripts the confrontation the
interview the stuff that didn't
necessarily make the show at the time
and you see this pattern of grooming and
this normalization of adult sex to
children
and this
conversation where they try to relate to
a child at a child's level
and it follows a pattern and it's
effective because it works
it works time and time again so if you
eliminate that
you educate
and you prepare
your child
and you have the conversation you have
the conversation and they have to feel
comfortable coming to you you're not
going to take away the internet of the
community
do you have kids
yeah mine are grown i mean my my kids my
two oldest are in the business let's
just say let's just say you're you have
a 10 year old kid today
role play with us what's the
conversation you have a son or you have
a daughter how do you have the
conversation i'm going to let you
visit youtube okay
but i'm going to put protections on this
and you need to know that there are
people on youtube who are creating
content or making shows
that at first appear to be appropriate
for children
cartoonish but they're not
they're intended to trick you so i'm
going to watch closely
and monitor the content that you view
the shows you watch on youtube and if i
see anything
we're going to have a conversation
and if anybody ever comes to you
who you don't know in real life and
wants to be your friend you need to tell
me about it i'm not going to punish you
but you need to tell me because
why because there are people out there
who want to hurt kids it's a sad reality
of life
it's it's sad but it's true
there are people that's why we have
police that's why we have the fbi that's
why
god created parents however you want to
phrase it with your belief system in
your own home
i'm here to protect you i'm not here to
punish you and you need to tell me if
something light happens and if there is
a bad guy out there who tries to do
something with you we'll go after him
together now are you specifically saying
youtube for a reason because i would
feel like snapchat would be probably
i use it just yeah snapchat using that
as a tick tock snapchat whatever it is
and the thing that that you really have
to be careful with
when the kids get on and play these
interactive games because somebody
posing as a 13 year old in st louis
could be a 55 year old in his mother's
basement wearing his underwear
surrounded by pizza boxes trying to
trick kids
you create these images in a kid's mind
and they get it right but i'll tell you
this early on in the predator
investigations i had a
a group of maybe a dozen 13 14 year olds
and i said show of hands
how many of you been have been
approached online by an adult and it
made you uncomfortable
99
oh wow
how many of you told your parents
too
so they just don't feel comfortable
telling their parents if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]